ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاش الملف الثانيه
بالاجماع اعتمد مجلس النواب الفرنسي قرارا
يدعو الحكومه الفرنسيه والاتحاد الاوروبي
الى ادراج مجموعه فاغنر على قائمه
المنظمات الارهابيه على خلفيه انشطتها في
اوكرانيا ودول افريقيه ودعت الجمعيه
الوطنيه الفرنسيه دعت حكومتها كذلك الى
التعبئه الدبلوماسيه من اجل ان يتبنى
الاتحاد الاوروبي هذا المطلب الوثيقه
اقترحها بامين حداد وهو نائب عن باريس
ويتبع حزب النهضه الذي يتزعمه الرئيس
الفرنسي ماكرون هذا النص غير الملزم
يستهدف اتهامات للمجموعه بارتكاب تجاوزات
بحق مدنيين في اوكرانيا والتي توصف بجرائم
حرب كما يسعى لاتاحه فرص اكثر لفرض عقوبات
اكثر فعاليه على اعضاء مجموعه فاجنر وعلى
الجهات الداعمه لها خصوصا رئيس الاوكراني
كان من اول المرحبين بهذه المبادره داعيا
العالم اجمع لتبنيها في حين نددت بها
موسكو ووصفتها بانها مغالاه في معاداه
روسيا ومن المحتمل ان تنظر جمعيه الوطنيه
الفرنسيه قريبا في قرار اخر يرمي الى
ادانه الترحيل موسكو اطفالا اوكرانيين الى
اراضي خاضعه لسيطرتها
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من موسكو
ومن باريس جون ميلان الباحث في شؤون
الجماعات المسلحه اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام
واسمحوا لي ان ابدا باريس معك
هل تعتقد بان الوقت قد حان فعليا لان تضاف
مجموعه فاجنر على قائمه المنظمات
الارهابيه للاتحاد الاوروبي
مساء الخير وشكرا على الاستضافه يبدو ان
الحاله هي كذلك اذا البرلمان لتواني بدا
بتصنيف تلك المجموعه من بين المنظمات
الارهابيه
وتبعه البرلمان الفرنسي
وثم بريطانيا العظمى
ختمت هذه
جوله من
الادانات
لتلك المجموعه
الجدير بالذكر ان هذا القرار ليس
رمزيا فقط هناك تبعات وعقوبات مثل
تجميد الاموال منع دخول
افراد والمسؤولين طبعا الى الاراضي
الاوروبيه وكل ذلك يمهد في يومنا الايام
محاكمه بعض الاشخاص الكبار مثل ب ريوجين
اذا
تمتع بالحياه الى هذه النقطه
هل تعتقد بان المستهدف الرئيسي من هكذا
توجه سواء فرنسي بريطاني او اوروبي عموما
المصادفه رئيسي هي المجموعه ام روسيا
هذا ليس شيئا غريبا بتصنيف مجموعه
كمنظمه الارهابيه لان فرنسا على اعلى
المستوى طالبوا تصنيف الرئيس الدوله
الروسيه
ارهابي الدولي اتهاماته مهمه وكذلك
المانيا وكذلك بعض الدول الاوروبيه كلهم
يعني هذا من اساليب
حرب الاعلاميه علاج ترافق الاحداث الجاريه
في اوكرانيا بلا ايشيك حيث
دور كبير في خصوصا في منطقه
مخلوط وارجونيوس
وطبعا فرنسا خصوصا كانت مزعجه بدور
فاجنر في افريقيا في افريقيا قسمها
الفرانكفورنيا هذا مالي وكذلك
الجمهوريه افريقيه المركزيه
كلهم طردوا
قواتنا الخبراء
الفرنسيين ومنذ كم يوم
سمى
وجود القوات الخاصه فرنسيه في جمهوريه
افريقيه المركزيه
الارهابيه وعنصريه على جمال لاعب دورا بدا
وهذا جواب على تلك التصريحات الذي كانت
تقريبا
ضيفي هو يقول لماذا
تحرم الاخرين مما تحلله على نفسها فرنسا
لسنوات كانت حاضره في مالي بقواتها
المعروفه
بجيشها بخبرائها
وتحكمت حتى لا نقول بانها اتخذت سلطه
معينه في داخل مالي قبل ان تعيد قواتها
طبعا وتخرجهم من معلم مؤخرا ولكن لماذا هي
تحلل لنفسها وتمنع مثلا مجموعه شركه
كافنير في ان تستعملها روسيا لاهداف تخصها
هي كذلك
اولا كان الجيش الفرنسي موجودا في مالي
بناء او ردا على مطلب من الدوله الماليه
بعد ذلك حصل انقلاب وتغيرت القياده
الماليه
وارادت ان
تطلب خدمات تلك المجموعه وتلك المجموعه لا
يمكنها ان تقارن
بدوله ديمقراطيه مثل فرنسا هي مجموعه
عباره عن ميليشيا متورطه بجرائم حرب بل
تفتخر بهذا الاسلوب الاجرامي عندما مثلا
جندات
اسرى او
مساجين من السجون الروسيه احدهم
فره من من
فقتل بطريقه شنيعه
باستعمال مطرقه وصوروا ذلك
لارهاب
البقيه من تلك
المجموعات
الاسرى وغير المحترفين في القتال
فهي مجموعه موجوده في سوريا
وليبيا وربما السودان اما في بلدان مثل
[موسيقى]
مالي
وغيرها من بلدان افريقيا الوسطى
لم تفعل حتى الان الا حراسه
القيادات العسكريه صحيح ولكن
هذه المجموعه موجوده منذ سنوات لماذا في
هذا التوقيت بالتحديد هذا التوجه الفرنسي
بمطالبه الاتحاد الاوروبي ان يدرجها على
قائمه المنظمات الارهابيه هل للتاثير على
سير المعارك في اوكرانيا
وطبعا لان شاهدنا في الايام الاخيره مشاهد
عجيبه حيث قائد تلك المجموعه
اتهم وشتم على اركان الجيش الروسي وهناك
تعبير غريب تكلم عن الجاد السعيد في موسكو
لا نعرف اذا دل على الوزراء ام اذا دل على
الرئيس بوتين وكانت لهجته قاسيه
وانتقاداته لاذعه اذ زعم ان مجموعته حرمت
من
شانها من الذخائر نعم فهذا خطير جدا لذلك
اتكلم عن محاكمه دوليه ممكنه يعني في يوم
من الايام ربما الرئيس بوتين سيتخلص من
هذا الرجل
القوي
كي يتحمل
فرنسا تخاف على مصلحه بوتين طيب انقل هذه
النقطه لك
قلت بانه طيب وضح وضح هذه النقطه خليني
افهم اكثر
لا يعني
مجموعه
اصبحت بذاتها مشكله كبرى ليس في افريقيا
فقط
نحن نشكر طبعا فرنسا على اهتمام الكبير
حول المشاكل الداخليه الروسيه
علاقات اتفاقنر مع وزاره الدفاع موجوده
مشاكل موجوده ولكن نحن نحل هذه المشكله
بكل لبسات هذا شام روسي ليس شام فرنسي
وليست لفرنسا ان يستغلوا هذه التناقضات في
الداخل قوات
مسلح الروسيه التي تقود المعارك في بخموت
هذا الدفاعا عن جيش الروسي دفاعا مجرد
الدفاع الروسيه نحن ليست بحادشه بحاجه
تلك
النصائح نسايخ او مساعده الفرنسيه لذلك
انا اقول انه
وجود فادينر في كل المكان في افريقيا في
روسيا هذا مشرع
تدور المشرع في افريقيا
قطعوا علاقات على اساس الامن وفي في مجال
الامن
سياسه الداخليه عسكريه
واتفقوا مع ابراج الشركه خاصه ولذلك هذا
شان ليست وما فرضت
ارادتها الى الحكومه ولا
جمهوريه في افريقيا هذا اختارت هل
المساعده العسكريه
ولكنها تبقى مجموعه
ارتكبت جرائم حرب بحسب بعض التقارير
الدوليه باختصار
الجهات الامميه الجهات الدوليه التي
اوروبيه لانه هناك جرائم حرب هناك حتى قتل
الاعضاء في حرب اوكرانيا يقال بان هناك
عمليه اعدام لبعض الاعضاء الذين اختاروا
ان ينسحبوا من هذه المعركه كل هذه
التفاصيل على فكره لنوردها بطريقه مثبته
ولكن هذا ما يروج له حتى بعض السياسيين
ساخدم معك باختصار شديد مهما تكون الاهداف
هل تعتقد بانه اذا ما تم ضم هذه المجموعه
مجموعه فاجنر على قائمه المنظمات
الارهابيه التي اتحاد الاوروبي سيؤثر ذلك
على حرب اوكرانيا باختصار ان تكرمت
اذا انا اسمع انا اتهامات افاقنر انه هو
داخله كثير
العناصر من سجون الروسيه هذا لكي
يحول في المعارك هذا بموافقه الحكومه
الروسيه ليس هذا للحكومه تتهم حكومه رشيه
على الارهاب على الجرائم الحرب على اي شيء
هذا هذا قرار فرنسي هذا قرار الاوروبي
وليست قرار مؤمن المتحده
يسمونه مناسبه الارهابيه هذا
يوصف فرنسيين الروسيا يعتبرونها
موضوعا للمتابعه لانه يبدو ان هناك توجه
اوروبي عام لادراجه على قائمه المنظمات
الارهابيه شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكو
السابق وشكر كذلك لحظرتك من باريس الباحث
في شؤون الجامعات المسلحه
[موسيقى]
قصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات